a new report shows Hurricane Maria is
officially the most deadly u.s. natural
disaster in the last century were tacos
government requested an independent
review it found that Maria killed an
estimated two thousand nine hundred and
seventy five people now that's more than
forty six times the original official
death toll of sixty four David Beck
knows covered this story from the very
beginning he was back in Puerto Rico
today David good morning Gail good
morning there's a lot of Puerto Ricans
who think this story should be getting a
lot more attention than it is but here
we are on the island to tell you this
one of the most glaring findings in that
report is that doctors did not have the
proper training to know how to classify
a death is being storm related no no one
in the government had the experience and
that either so when the government was
telling us there were 64 people who died
they were talking about direct deaths
like flying debris or drowning but they
weren't accounting for people who died
because of things like the fact that the
power went out it just got me sad
Nicole Cordero told us that her 47 year
old mother Wanda indirectly died as a
result of Hurricane Maria Wanda had
pancreatitis and needed oxygen when the
power went out at the hospital where she
was being treated
I wish the hospital a government
Commission review done by George
Washington University researchers looked
at the six months after Hurricane Maria
and compared the number of deaths to the
same time period in seven previous years
the findings bumped the official death
toll from an estimated sixty four to two
thousand nine hundred seventy five the
mayor of San Juan called the new report
painful and shameful and said the
governor should take more responsibility
when I saw people dying I opted to shout
it
I opted to ask for help when others saw
people dying they opted to shut up
Governor Ricardo Rose say yo
acknowledged Tuesday that he's made
mistakes the focus shouldn't be hey
let's blame all these folks the focus
should be who's gonna be accountable and
who's gonna take the action so that this
doesn't happen again researchers found
that the government and hospitals were
inadequately prepared for the category
four storm they also found that the risk
of death was forty-five percent higher
those living in low-income areas on the
island and that elderly men were at the
greatest risk of dying but there were
young people who were otherwise healthy
like 29 year old Romsey Romero who also
died his brother Christian told us that
Romsey contracted a treatable bacterial
disease he had been helping his
community clean up after the hurricane
okay we're gonna point any handy I think
the government was negligent Christian
told us what is your brother deserve
efya I think my brother deserves justice
President Trump has not directly
commented on the new death toll or
tweeted about it but nor the White House
says he is proud of the federal
government's response here David Pegg
know who's been reporting this from the
very beginning in Puerto Rico thank you
David